bonsoir aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
parler d'un cocktail un cocktail
extraordinaire un cocktail
extraordinaire que chacun d'entre vous
aient pu prendre un cocktail
extraordinaire par les parfums et
saveurs que vous découvriez un cocktail
extraordinaire par la magie du lieu où
vous le buvez un cocktail extraordinaire
par les personnes qui vous entourent et
tout récemment rencontré avec lesquels
vous commenciez tout juste à tisser des
liens
ce cocktail extraordinaire vous fait
peut-être voyager vers un autre pays
vers un autre continent
c'était un cocktail extraordinaire parce
que vous sentiez bien dans un pays que
vous découvriez avec des gens qui
parlaient une autre langue que la vôtre
une langue comme vous que vous
maîtrisiez tout juste mais vous vous
sentiez bien car vous aviez l'impression
de vivre quelque chose de nouveau
d'incroyables d'unique dans votre vie
avec des gens des jeunes de votre âge
qui vivent est peut-être cette même
expérience ou qui vous inviter à
découvrir leur vie leur culture
ces jeunes c'était peut-être tout comme
vous des étudiants venus d'un autre pays
expatriate d'un semestre où des
étudiants qui vous inviter chez eux dans
leurs universités sur le campus
vous étiez bien qu'à vous croquer à
pleines dents cette expérience de vie
que vous offrez votre formation
chaque année des millions d'étudiants
10es rencontres uniques chaque année des
millions d'étudiants boivent des
cocktails extraordinaire
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler de
ce qu'ils doivent se battre pour venir
prendre ce cocktail avec vous ainsi
pierre aura beaucoup de difficultés à
venir trinquer avec vous les économies
qu'il aura réalisé pour aller visiter le
mexique serviront finalement à financer
les soins dont il a besoin au quotidien
en effet sa caisse d'assurance ne pourra
pas financer les soins de nabeul douleur
a besoin dans le pays d'accueil car il
n'a pas d'accord bilatéral avec la
france
de plus des assurances privées refusent
de couvrir des soins déjà prévus vous ne
croiserez pas non plus sarah sarah se
faisaient une joie de venir réaliser un
stage en entreprise en angleterre mais
et sarah non voyantes
en fait elle a beaucoup tout se passe
bien dans l'entreprise mais des soucis
commencent quand elle veut sortir comme
dans la vie sociale
elle a beaucoup de mal à trouver des
associations qui lui propose des
activités accessibles
de plus son chien guide déstabilisé par
la conduite à gauche ne peut pas
l'emmener ou très difficilement à
circuler dans son quartier si vous allez
vers un autre continent
vous ne croiserez pas non plus guillaume
tout simplement parce qu'il n'aura pas
pu aller aussi loin
en effet devant récupérer ces
médicaments régulièrement en france il a
dû choisir une pays une destination dans
un pays limitrophe certains médicaments
ne peuvent pas être délivrée pour
plusieurs mois
enfin émane
on va pas venir à la soirée que vous
organisez dans ce bar typique car les
transports en commun sont difficilement
accessibles et les transports adaptés
beaucoup trop cher ils sont nombreux les
étudiants qui chaque année ne peuvent
pas choisir la destination de leurs
rêves ni même partir à l'étranger pour
des problèmes de surcoût excessif pour
un problème de manque d'information de
manque de dispositifs qui permettent de
maintenir le la garantie des soins ou de
maintenir les services des deux dômes
ici quand ils partent à l'étranger
il ya bientôt huit ans depuis bientôt
huit ans j'ai je suis en chargé
d'accompagner des étudiants en situation
de handicap afin qu'ils puissent réussir
leurs études et s'insérer dans la
dynamique sociale du corpus un job
passionnant auquel je suis très attaché
et qui m'invitent toujours plus à
m'engager pour ces étudiants afin qu'ils
aient uniquement à penser à leurs études
et non pas à la mise en place d
accompagnement des aménagements qui leur
sont nécessaires
ce job et cette ambition nous sommes des
centaines en france à les partager avec
mes homologues des grandes écoles et des
universités
nous travaillons ensemble a essayé de
trouver des solutions à des
problématiques communes rencontrées par
ces étudiants sur nos différents corpus
il y a deux ans nous avons voulu nous
attaquer à l'une des plus grandes
d'entre elles
l'accès à la mobilité internationale
alors oui devant nous ouvrir un océan
une infinité de défi qui paraissait
insurmontable mais un avenir qui se met
à l'horizon qui se promenaient qui était
prometteur là commence
relative aux droits des personnes
handicapées de l'onu mentionne danser
dans ses différents articles
la garantie d'accès à l'autonomie à la
mobilité à l'éducation à la santé et aux
activités récréatives sportives et
culturelles
trois associations ont voulu s'appuyer
sur cette convention pour proposer un
outil spécifique pour ces étudiants
depuis bientôt deux ans elle porte un
plaidoyer en faveur de la création d'un
statut international d'étudiants en
situation de handicap
nous ne demandons pas de nouveaux droits
pour ces étudiants nous demandons
simplement l'application des droits qui
sont mentionnés dans cette convention à
leur destination
nous demandons à chaque pays que qu'il
nomme dans chaque ambassade
un référent handicap qui leur
conseillera tout ressortissant sur les
des établissements les structures d'aidé
à domicile des dans le combat des dans
le contre quotidien pardon et qui
conseille aussi sur les associations qui
proposent des activités accessibles
nous demandons à ce que soit créé un
bagage supplémentaire gratuit dans les
avions pour faciliter le transport des
médicaments et du matériel adapté
nous demandons à ce que les traitements
puissent être délivrée pour l'ensemble
du séjour et si cela n'est pas possible
et que ces traitements puissent être
trouvées dans le pays d'accueil qu'ils
soient remboursés par la caisse
d'assurance de l'étudiant tout comme les
soins dont ils ont besoin
nous voulons en effet que le statut
international vaille d'accord bilatéral
dans le cadre de des échanges
internationaux pour ces étudiants
enfin partout dans le monde nous voyons
des moyens de transport adaptés se
développer il ya deux jours il ya deux
ans j'étais au cambodge
j'ai même vu des touques adapté aux
personnes en fauteuil roulant comment
pouvons nous accepter qu aujourd'hui des
étudiants en situation de handicap n'est
pas un accès à moindre coût assez
transport adapté tous ces droits
seraient rappelés dans un document
international unique administratif alors
oui devant nous un océan
mais aujourd'hui on peut le dire nous
apercevons la terre en effet la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme et le conseil national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
nous ont invités à nous saisir de
l'occasion de l'examen périodique
universel de la france qui a eu lieu en
janvier 2018 afin de promouvoir ce
projet
la contribution que nous avons écrite a
été présentée à des parlementaires à
différents ministères et à la présidence
de la république française à un niveau
international
la rapporteure spéciale pour les droits
des personnes handicapées de l'onu et le
spécialiste handicap de l'organisation
internationale du travail oit également
bien accueilli cette nouvelle idée au
niveau de l'onu
cette instance internationale attend
qu'un état membre se saisissent de ce
projet est le porte devant ces
différentes instances de l'onu
voilà parce que nous en tant que
association ne pouvons nous ne pouvons
pas aller plus loin dans notre plaidoyer
ne pouvons faire que du plaidoyer il y a
quelques mois en octobre lors d'un
colloque international
la secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées a invité les
différents pays représentés à se saisir
de ce projet avec la france
depuis deux ans nous avons réalisé à
plaidoyer incroyable nous sommes fier
très fier mais surtout nous sommes fiers
de ces étudiants que nous accompagnons
et qui par leur persévérance au
quotidien nous invite à traverser ces
océans alors
alors ce soir l'espoir l'espérance que
je voulais vous partager c'est tout
simplement qu'un jour vous veniez me
raconter le souvenir d'un de ces
cocktails extraordinaire que vous aurez
pris avec vos amis y compris pop pierre
sahara emma et guillaume santé
[Applaudissements]